c'est parti pour les soldes d'hiver du 9
janvier au 12 février le centre
commercial de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
met en place différentes opérations de
marketing ce matin ouverture des
magasins des 8h30 en plus pour les
clients qui étaient dans le centre vous
avez le droit un petit déjeuner ou faire
par les commerçants et une manière de
les accueillir tandir bon bienvenue pour
les soldes et puis bah voilà de se faire
plaisir quoi
parmi les clients déjà nombreux certains
font preuve d'organisations j'avais déjà
fait repérage la semaine dernière et là
c'est bon voilà j'achète ce que j'avais
prévu d'acheter encore les tailles donc
profitons chargés de faire les courses
aussi pour mon mari donc du coup voilà
même là en général on essaye de se faire
une petite cagnotte pour justement
pouvoir en profiter quand ce sont les
soldes on est à peu près 100 euros pour
chacun vous avez un budget
oui il faut pas que ça dépasse aller les
200 euros en même temps je regarde je
sais pas je regarde je cherche des
costards éventuellement mais j'attends
déjà que ce soit moins cher
et puis là je vais essayer de faire de
bonnes affaires
on commence toujours par entre 20 et 30%
en début pour finir à la fin des
vraiment en fin des soldes à 50% on
n'attaque pas sur les prix à 70% qu'on
pourrait le faire certains on préfère
avoir un prix qui soit tout en
adéquation avec nos produits on
sélectionne pas on met réellement tout
le magasin toute la collection donc de
la saison en solde ça a une grosse
partie du du travail de l'année c'est
comme ça toutes les périodes de sol
c'est aussi bien celle d'été mais c'est
vrai que ceux de l'hiver ça représente
oui beaucoup
dans cette boutique de prêt-à-porter
pour homme les soldes d'hiver
correspondent à 20% du chiffre
d'affaires malgré la crise le magasin
espère dépasser ce pourcentage pour
faire mieux que l'an dernier la période
des sols s'achèvera le 12 février avec
une ouverture spéciale dimanche 13
janvier dans plusieurs centres
commerciaux de la région